Justin Trudeau how many more babies have
to be murdered until you will call a
ceasefire it's the prime minister's
dinner where the main course's protests
delivered tableside ceas fire now ceas
fire now after a day of political events
Justin trudo dining on personal time
Tuesday evening at viges off the PM
security detail moving protesters back
and getting Trudeau out prime minister
apologizing to other diners and then
talking with Vic viage before leaving
there should be some expectation not
necessarily of absolute privacy but some
capacity to to just uh to be on their
own or be with friends the PM then went
to cocktail bar banga at Main and
Keir around 250 protesters showed up
there as well and so did around 100
police officers VPD saying they had no
advanced notice a scuffle broke out and
a police officer was hurt she was
assaulted Ed by a protester Who We
Believe punched her in the face and
attempted to gouge around her eyes yaka
morwitz was arrested and charged another
protester was arrested for obstructing
police he was released without charge
Global News reached out to the groups
who posted these videos online but
interview requests were turned down our
officers responded with the intention of
controlling the crowd managing the crowd
facilitating a peaceful protest certain
people within that crowd uh engaged
unlawful Behavior Trudeau no stranger to
protest this comes as his party
continues to struggle in the polls
during the last election right-wing
truck Convoy supporters hurled both
insults and rocks the challenge of being
a centralist party in Canada is that
he's criticized from the right and he's
criticized from the left The Vancouver
Police also noting there's been a surge
of protests both political and
non-political this year and the
expectation is there will be more than
1,000 such events in 20 23 Richard Wiman
Global News Victoria